anything in this textbook that we're
going to be as Americans religious right
he starts out talking about telling
stories yeah
use of the word merits and he goes back
and forth within esquema and he'll do
that throughout why does he start out
with telling stories because this book
and an ending account of religion
America ultimately has to be telling
some sort of set of stories or some
overarching story and there's this
question is it possible so he have one
here's a key word here at the store you
can you can tell one story like you
could say well you know the Puritans
came here and then I've everything went
to crap after that that would be one
coherent story would that be an accurate
story no because you're leaving an awful
lot of people out and it doesn't seem
like it's actually correct to say them
all one to know the heat after this so
when people were doing religious studies
for a long time they intended to tell
the story like he says from a
perspective that was kind of narrow it
was what we could call the Protestant
consensus yeah this tended to be not
just any process you know biscuit aliens
and Lutheran's you know liturgical
oriented Protestants were kind of left
on the picture and of course Catholics
Jews you know Eastern Orthodox they were
kind of left out of the picture as well
we're actually turning to the bad guys
if you look at a lot of the narratives
about the religious history of the
United States that are you know told
early on they view it as this you know
city on a hill and
as doing something quite different but
also getting away from the decadent
Europeans and the things that they were
involved in over time and there's a lot
of reasons for the city's going to go
into the picture gets big and it widens
and more people get involved in telling
the story and with time you get a lot of
Catholic voices involved a lot of Jewish
voices involved so by the 1950s you can
actually have a book called Protestant
Catholic Jew as a history of American
religion talking about those as being
like the great themes and things start
to get more complicated as time to us
and I like he says we end up expanding
this to all sorts of other groups that
have been that have been sort of
marginalized left on the picture who are
those include would have been left out
maybe they don't think about this when
did america start with the Constitution
with the Puritans here before you know
Native Americans we want to tell the
story of religion in America there were
people practicing religious before that
explorers got here everybody's you know
perspectives equally represented in us
african-americans
that immigration only come from Europe
or forced integration from Africa yeah
yeah and so you know we have to think
about other well let's just put down
this this is gonna be really
generalizing but we'll call it world
religions right I don't have to write a
million things on the board for Hindus
coming from from India from Indonesia
other parts of what was at one time
called Greater India Buddhists coming
from a variety of countries Daoists
confucius practitioners of ancestral
Chinese religion Shinto practitioners
from Japan Muslims from all over the
globe and so a stream it's not a lot of
them left in the world a lot they all a
lot of people have been coming here from
many different places for quite a long
time and bringing their religions with
them so if we want to tell a story
that's that's inclusive we want to
incorporate those voices but now we end
up with it with a different sort of
problem don't we because what happens
when imagining like right now if
everyone was just start talking would it
be like in this room yeah could you
follow it anyone conversation
imagine that you guys are all talking
and not just like you know talking about
the same thing but about totally
different things
and I'm up here trying to lecture and
like you know you're actually trying to
listen could you actually pay attention
to what I'm saying
probably that it would be it'd be a
badly literally and when we when we
start to you know say everybody is gonna
have you know their their own point of
view that's one of the dangers for that
that it just degenerates into
everybody's got their own little bubble
that they're in and you can hear what
people are saying on that but you get
outside
it's sort of a wash stories none of them
match up to each other exact map on to
each other and so we want to do what
he's trying to do in this book is
provide something that has at least you
know a nod to being representative to
incorporating as many voices as possible
into the story but also focuses on the
things that are most central the things
that are most determinative the things
that are most relevant that's why it's
got the order that it does he also wants
to talk about a number of different
important themes that are coming up lots
are blurb on stories talk about religion
we can talk about private religion and
public religion or he actually uses the
term person so what is personal religion
that's you know what what an individual
person he has dodds
thanks Longstone to them so to speak
religious autobiography would be an
example of this that he talks about
individual narratives I guess you could
put in you know things that are involved
with a family over time could fit in
with that as well so public religion is
what he's going to focus on and why well
because you know if you want to actually
have a book you know this is a pretty
thick book but if you want to have any
sort of unity you can't focus on every
single person's story
Kanyon you got a look at the things that
are that they all have in common the
things that are more determinative the
bigger picture items and so we want to
think for a little bit and he leads us
through this about what is public
religion
anymore so what is public its structures
structures that groups or communities or
traditions have in common
women practicing a religion or when
you're looking at what you study you're
generally looking at things that people
have in common that are connected so
what are these some you know common
elements that religious groups or
communities faiths whatever you want to
call them that they all today out she
ends up talking about this term
tradition
what's a tradition because that's family
traditions and your parents come and
visit you up here every once in a while
we're down here from further upstate you
go to the same place same diner
lots of diners you're on here maybe take
you out to buy something nice that can
be a tradition you can do it a number of
times and then like if your kids go to
MERIS and your you know their legacy you
might do the same thing say when I was a
kid might you know when I was in school
my mom and dad used to do this with me
and I found this kind of meaningful so
I'm gonna pass it on to you do you do
anything around the holidays when they
had break to just go home and see some
old friends Ben did go out a few times
watch some movies or did you do anything
that's tied together with that part of
the earth is there a tree in any of your
houses maybe a fake tree it had some
stuff on it
lights tinsel maybe have you had a real
trip
that's a tradition right if you go home
and you're used to that sort of thing
and there's no tree you kind of wonder
what's going on are mom and dad slipping
there's somebody depressed what you know
what's happened here that they you know
lose their Christmas spirit and then
there's all sorts of other things you
know we're gonna run into another set of
traditions pretty soon originally you
know there's some sort of I guess
religious background to it but now it's
more of a commercial holiday giving you
a pink red and white what are those of
colors for Valentine's Day you know
everybody better to start buying cards
and stocking up on flowers and spreading
some poems and you know getting
reservations that sort of thing that's a
tradition and the same thing happens
with religion you know you do the same
thing over and over and over yeah and it
happens over generations and it becomes
something that is integral so what you
do becomes party your your life it
providing is like it says overarching
meaning and order to people's lives if
you go to church every Sunday what does
it feel like when you don't go to church
maybe they don't like going to church
it's like yeah this is this is great
I think I can finally sleep in it but if
you like that sort of thing you feel
kind of in an emptiness it kind of
what's wrong here sort of thing that's
because that's a tradition that provides
meaning and order in people's lives
and traditions are tied in with entire
culture great example of this what they
call Sunday laws in some states you
can't like say buy liquor or a beer on
Sunday Indiana's
as I found out I came from Wisconsin
where we could buy beer pretty much all
the time I worked in a gas station
actually I need a Class C liquor license
so I could sell you know all the stuff
that we sold in gas stations to people
that's all much they like that yeah
you're a liquid then I remember my
relatives lived in Indiana this is when
I was in college going out on a Sunday
night and going to the local pharmacy
where you would buy beer and we'd run
out of beer so we went and I walk up
there to the front and I can't solve
that I'm of age yeah and she said well
it's Sunday so what well we just don't
sell beer at first I thought it was a
store and so I said well who does and
she said well I mean you can go across
the state line to Illinois because
they'll sell it over there that was only
45 minutes in the state line we didn't
actually do that but I was like wait
wheezing this whole state you don't sell
beer on something why the hell not
well because somebody felt that you know
sunday is the day of rest the Lord's Day
and this was an institutionalization of
something that was part of part of a
culture by the way the Supreme Court has
ruled that those sort of laws aren't in
fact constitutional if they serve some
secular purpose tradition and culture
tend to be something that that exists in
people and in communities what Shores
them up what we call institutions
from example of institution would be a
church and you could think of you know
the individual church building when you
have a church building is the church
just the building sometimes you know if
like if there's nobody going to it I
suppose you did say it's that church but
what else is the church that's kind of
that Church of it's just a building what
else is the church yeah yeah and there's
always been be like people going in and
going out some people are closer to the
center there'll be some sort of core
that constitutes that yeah now if that
church actually belongs to a larger
group they might also use the word
church for that so think about you know
for example Catholics there's one thing
that's called Church that's about a
billion members worldwide and then
there'll be you know the church
associated with each arch diocese or
diocese and then each of those will have
a whole slew of individual churches
called local churches and each one of
those is a church you know all those are
examples of institutions there you've
got institution at several levels
something Baptist Convention would be an
example of an institution they say
convention instead of Church because
they have a different sort of
associational model where they like VOC
to get together and if they don't like
what's going on with the convention they
can leave but it's still the same thing
it's an institution a Hindu temple would
be an example of an institution a
synagogue we could go on and on so those
are those are important what also we
missing out of this picture well we
often have people who are
charged with with being more central to
this this sort of business don't bury
being at the heart of it and we use this
term clergy for them this sort of a
generic term that could be a Muslim Imam
that could be a Hebrew Cantor that could
be a rapper and that could be you know
clergy here doesn't necessarily need
somebody who's presiding over services
it could be the religious like monks and
nuns many different religions kind of
ascetic members of the society or belong
to that and most of the people who are
you know charged with like making sure
that everything gets passed down right
and that the rituals are done correctly
and then they also tend to do something
important that's called theology you
have a theology one we mean by that for
using in this very generic sense it's
the reflection upon the practices the
beliefs the doctrines the reveal things
that they believe to connect them with
the divine so you know Martin Luther
King to use him as an example Martin
Luther King was a theologian a lot of
people don't realize that he wasn't just
about organizing marches he was
organizing marches because he thought
that was what the gospel required and he
provides you with arguments about how
this actually comes out of the gospel
great example are back would be letter
from a Birmingham jail by the way you
know that letter was written - it wasn't
written to the police chief of
Birmingham it was written to a lot of
other clergy including other black
Virgie who are criticizing him and
saying you shouldn't be doing what
you're doing
the Bible says obey the law and you're
breaking the law so he was actually
making an argument saying yeah these are
unjust laws here's how to understand
them is unjust once he actually drew up
others
like st. Augustine and st. Thomas
Aquinas making his argument if you have
a letter from a Birmingham jail you
should read it it's really a brilliant
piece of work
and it's an example on their theology
wasn't just you know public relations it
was actually theology he was working out
what his religious viewpoint required
that's why it's such an important
document for American history
these are all aspects of public religion
and we're going to be paying attention
to all of these over the course of the
semester you want to know these terms
because we're going to be using these
and the textbook is going to be using
them quite frequently the last thing
that we're going to pin on there's a
number of different themes that this
author thinks are particularly connected
with America
and we're not going to have time to go
into each one of those it gives you a
list of these there we go page six he
says that one of the things that's been
really exceptional in America that this
denomination was in later he talks about
mobility immigration British culture
slavery embrace democracy populism
capitalism nationalism pluralism and
Americanization you might say you know
that's an awful lot of jargon terms
why is he laying those out for you it
gives you it like a little rundown in a
paragraph for the pre twenties why these
are central themes for American religion
and the history of American religion and
what's going on and how they still
impact it today so mobility what does he
mean by that he talks about social
mobility and being able to move from
place to place that is something that is
particularly America in comparison to
where people were coming from you know
this is this was a place where you could
move up do that they would actually
trade up churches immigration one of
these going to make a distinction there
between forced immigration like slavery
consistent and voluntary immigration
British culture America is a mixture of
a lot of different cultures the British
culture set sort of the pattern and
predominated for quite some time
slavery and race is a very important
part of American religion
history democracy itself a lot of
denominations even even ones that are
very hierarchical like like you know
Catholicism and orthodoxy they tended to
take on a more democratic more
responsive to the populist kind of kind
of mode to them capitalism that's going
to be an important thing to talk about
America was always from from the
beginning that is a country within the
the global marketplace and so it's
definitely been a pre-capitalist
beginning the way a lot of European
countries today and it's interesting
because a lot of people will talk about
churches behaving in a capitalistic
manner you know going after market share
those would be things of all talk about
pluralism we've talked a little bit
about that and that Americanization a
lot of religious groups came here from
other places and he had a lot of you
know beliefs are already coming in
there's not a ton of new groups that
started within the United States
themselves but they became Americanized
so we want to think over the course of
the semester what does that mean what is
distinctive about American approaches to
we're really a unique country in many
respects were the most religious first
world developed country a lot of the
other developed countries religion as
has go out on the wing that didn't
happen here in the United States the way
they happen in France or in Italy or in
Spain so we're gonna we're going to
think about a lot of these themes over
the course of semester these are just
some around the things written here but
those are some of the things that keep
in mind has been flour away through to
this this tax